UPDATED ITS PERCEPTION IN A
FEW DECADES.
PROFESSOR, THANK YOU FOR
BEING HERE TONIGHT.
I APPRECIATE IT?
>> THANK YOU FOR HAVING ME.
>> Tucker: WANT TO BRING YOU
A FOX NEWS ALERT.
DEMOCRATIC SENATOR MARK
WARNER OF VIRGINIA,
INFLUENCE HAS LEARNED,
TEXTED WITH YOU A RUSSIAN
OF THE TRUMP DOSSIER
FOX NEWS ED HENRY HAS THIS
STORY AND HE JOINS US WITH
DETAILS.
HEY, ED.
>> THESE TEXTS OBTAINED
EXCLUSIVELY BY FOX NEWS AND
THEY SHOW AND CAN YOU SEE
THEM RIGHT HERE I HAVE THEM
LEADING ONE OF THE
INVESTIGATIONS OF PRESIDENT
TRUMP'S TIES TO RUSSIA HAD
EXTENSIVE CONTACT WITH THAT
WARNER TEXTED AT ONE POINT
HE WOULD, QUOTE, RATHER NOT
HAVE A PAPER TRAIL IN CASE
HE COULD NOT SEAL AN
AGREEMENT WITH THE FORMER
BRITISH SPY TO TESTIFY.
STEELE SO FAR HAS NOT AGREED
HE BEGAN, WARNER DID,
TEXTING WITH THIS LOBBYIST
BILLIONAIRE OHLEG DAROPOSCO
HAD HIS VISA REVOKED BECAUSE
HE HAS TIES TO RUSSIA
ORGANIZED CRIME.
WARNER WANTED CONTACT WITH
STEELE WITHOUT ANYONE BEING
IN THE LOOP.
WE HAVE SO MUCH TO DISCUSS
WE NEED TO BE CAREFUL.
WE CAN HELP OUR COUNTRY
WALDMAN TEXTED ON MARCH 2
27B9D.
I'M IN WALDMAN WHO HAS A
ANOTHER TEXT QUOTE:  WE WANT
TO DO THIS RIGHT.
PRIVATE IN LONDON.
DON'T WANT TO SEND LETTER
HAVE PAPER TRAIL.
NOW, THE PANEL, THE SENATE
INTEL PANEL GOT THESE TEXTS
FROM WALDMAN LAST SEPTEMBER
AFTER THEY ASKED FOR THEM.
AND A WARNER AIDE
ACKNOWLEDGED THAT WARNER AND
RICHARD BURR, THE REPUBLICAN
CHAIRMAN REVEALED THE TEXTS
TO THEIR COLLEAGUES BECAUSE,
QUOTE, THEY REALIZE OUT OF
CONTEXT IT DOESN'T LOOK
GREAT FOR WARNER.
WARNER AND BURR STRESSED TO
FOX TONIGHT THAT THE
CHAIRMAN OF THE COMMITTEE
RICHARD BURR WAS IN THE LOOP
ABOUT THIS.
WALDMAN DID NOT RETURN CALLS
SEEKING COMMENT.
RETAINER IN 2000 AND 2010 TO
PETITION THE U.S. GOVERNMENT
ON BEHALF OF THAT RUSSIAN
BILLIONAIRE.
THAT BILLIONAIRE BY THE WAY
IS SUPPOSED TO HAVE TIES TO
PAUL MANAFORT WHICH IS WHY
THE COMMITTEE WANTED TO GET
TO HIM.
REMEMBER, THIS INVESTIGATION
STARTED WITH THESE VARIOUS
COMMITTEES AND NOW ROBERT
MUELLER LOOKING AT THE
PRESIDENT'S TIES TO RUSSIANS
NOW IS BEING TURNED AROUND A
>> Tucker: A LITTLE BIT?
IT DOESN'T LOOK GOOD.
WHEN A PRESIDENT SAYS -- A
SENATOR SAYS HE DOESN'T
WANT, QUOTE, A PAPER TRAIL,
THAT'S NOT GOOD.